my name
is Roseanne Ahmed
I'm a British
National
of Sydney's origin
and I am in Sudan
I have been hiding under my bed
for the past six hours
the area where I stay at the moment
has been shelled to shreds
I have heard nothing but explosions and
gunfire
and shelling
and screams
for the past six hours
only now
has it died down
this has been the case
for the past seven days straight
this war started on Saturday the 15th of
April
seven days later
seven days later we are still here
I am alive only by the grace of God and
by the strength
of my surrounding family members
thankfully are also still alive
saying that
we are all mentally
devastated
I
and my family members are terrified to a
point where we have gone numb
I don't know
why we have received no information
as to our evacuation
as a British national
I haven't heard anything from the
British Embassy
my only question is
if there is no plan
to get me out
please tell me why
if there are logistical issues if there
are airspace problems
I believe I should be aware
I should be updated as to why seven days
later
I am here
it is a shame
a real shame that I am not Ukrainian
it is a shame that this isn't some
eurocentric country because I imagine if
this wasn't an African country if I
wasn't of African origin my life would
be treated with a little more worth and
value and importance and priority
if there is no plan to get us to safety
again let us know why
this has been the most harrowing
experience of my life
and my only focus right now is to get to
my mother
who
is probably more pain than I am
and I need to understand
why we are still here
thank you very much
for giving me the opportunity to make
this very very clear
thank you